foreign
tours in California
they gave me this model that that I just
absolutely love
and we've turned it into something that
we do and they basically created
a
four quadrant thing you've seen these
axes many times with a y-axis and an
x-axis
and
in one of the quadrants there's the word
can
let's say the upper left hand it says
can and then in the upper right it says
can't
and then in the bottom left it says will
and in the bottom right it says won't
so you basically have someone's
technical abilities the Canon can't and
then you have somebody's emotional
willingness or aptitude and that's will
and won't
and so what we've been able to do we've
actually created mirrors
which we put in the locker rooms of our
restaurants and because we're not trying
to keep this a secret
and
The Mirror Has all four quadrants and so
when you go put on your uniform every
day
you get to look at yourself in the
mirror if you so choose and see this
quadrant
and so
basically
if you have someone who
will
but can't
that's a very different thing than
someone who won't and can
right or if you have someone totally who
you know I could go through all of them
but what we've basically done Tim is
that
we have an action point and a time frame
for each one of those
so if you've got somebody
who
can and will
right
I want to celebrate that person I want
to replicate that but I really want to
pay attempt those are my flowers I
really want to water them
too often we ignore those people because
oh that's easy we don't have to worry
about Johnny because he always gets it
right right you really want to water
those flowers and celebrate them
if you have someone who
can't but will
I'm going to coach them and I don't mind
saying this but the wick on my candle is
pretty long for someone
who will
right because if you can teach them how
to do the thing
and they're willing to do it and they've
got the right approach the right
Hospitality attitude
once they learn how to do it you're
going to have a loyal employee for life
because you stuck with them
now on the other hand so let's say
that's a six-month wick on my candle but
let's say you've got someone who can't
and won't
right right I'm gonna put the candle
underneath their rear end
and they're gonna they're gonna have to
learn that this isn't working and and
that's going to be a very very sure
that's got to be a short window because
the longer that person stays on the team
everyone else on the team says
why should I try if they keep
if they keep batting that person in the
lineup
instead of benching them or saying to
the minor leagues why should I try
the hardest one I find is the can but
won't
that's the person where you just go you
know you're you're way better than this
but for some reason you're just choosing
not to bring it here and so yeah that's
gonna that's gonna have a pretty short
life as well but by by actually naming
all four of those things it really
really helps us to have these
conversations and we tell people up
front so you're not having they see that
mirror
so it's not the first time you're having
this conversation it gives you a
language to say
here's where you are right now and it's
not working and I'll say probably the
greatest lesson I've learned
about
anything has been really trying to
understand how do you scale culture
and I've kind of come up with this
equation of my own mind that
took me a long time to get to I used to
think that
by rewarding the behaviors I wanted that
was the best way to fuel the culture I
wanted and now I look at it a little bit
differently because
that's turning a blind eye sometimes to
the behaviors I don't want
right so I've now learned that the
culture you have in your organization
is the sum
of all the wanted behaviors that you
celebrate minus All The Unwanted
behaviors that you tolerate
and
I've learned that the hard way because
people think I'm I'm full of crap they
can read anything I write about our
culture Etc but if I'm tolerating
behaviors
that don't promote either the Excellence
or well-being of the team then
everything I've done on the positive
side should be called into question
how might you these days having had much
more practice since your honeymoon
if you if you had to let somebody go or
you wanted to maybe suggest languages
someone might use but you could make it
personal how might you phrase that
conversation well the first thing is it
shouldn't be the first time you've had
the conversation yeah there's nothing
worse than when somebody feels like I
got whacked in the back of the head and
and they're just shocked because you had
never had the conversation you hadn't
had the tough conversation that said
either your performance or your behavior
it's one of the two
are not Measuring Up and that's another
reason that we have to be really clear
about what excellent performance looks
like and what The Wanted behaviors are
which we're very very clear about
and
by being upfront with people and not
having this be the first time you're
having the conversation it takes a lot
of the emotion out of it doesn't mean
someone's going to be happy but it's it
basically sounds like
I actually
something that
I I've said on a few occasions
not in the time I'm actually exiting
somebody but in the time leading up to
it is I use what I call the jigsaw
puzzle
analogy
we've all done jigsaw puzzles and like
the more challenging they are you get to
this point where
it's starting to take some shape but you
still have a lot more pieces
that you haven't put together than what
you have in your little shape there
and invariably you're going to come up
with a piece
that looks like it's right
and you put it down
and it's almost right
it's so almost right that you keep kind
of jiggering it around
to make it right even though you know
it's not right and the piece knows it's
not right and what starts to happen is
paper on top of the jigsaw piece starts
to fray a little bit
and in fact the jigsaw puzzle if you're
not if you keep trying starts to fray
well that's what we do too often with
employees that are almost right
but they're not really the right fit and
it ends up not being good for the puzzle
or for the puzzle piece
so I try to explain that to people
if you get that conversation with me
chances are probably 80 percent that the
next conversation is you're a beautiful
jigsaw piece but you should probably be
part of a different puzzle
it doesn't make you wrong doesn't make
you bad no if it's someone who actually
did something bad that's a very
different conversation it's like you
cannot work here you've betrayed
Integrity you've betrayed someone on our
team you've betrayed one of our guests
you betrayed our investors whatever
whatever if you cross any one of our
stakeholders
that's a very different conversation
lack of Integrity but if it's if it's
just not the right fit
it shouldn't be the number one it
shouldn't be the first time they've
heard about it
and
they may not love the conversation
who in the world wants to be exited yeah
but I'll tell you one thing I feel
really good about is that we have a
pretty small industry
and invariably if you're someone who
left our business on your terms or on
our terms
you're probably going to be serving me
in a restaurant sometime in New York
and I feel really good that I never mind
seeing these people it just feels like
as long as it's clean and we were honest
with each other it tends to work out in
the end